[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un nouveau
téléphone le tout nouveau téléphone au
nord europe qui est là le huit pros au
nord huit pros tout nouveau téléphone
qui était présentée aujourd'hui qui
s'annonce comme un téléphone pas si low
cost que ça est bien bien musclé en
termes de gamme on va comparer par
rapport au reste
[Musique]
déjà elle la semaine dernière ce que
samsung a présenté son fameux et suites
et suites et suit plus
on attend d'ici quelques mois l'iphone 8
d'apple et là on a je dirais un nouveau
téléphone qui est longtemps été
considéré comme un téléphone low cost à
mon avis à tort c'est ce fameux au nord
huit pros il y avait le 800e quelques
temps là le 8 pro à de nouvelles
caractéristiques techniques qui font que
c'est vraiment un modèle qui est boosté
un modèle puissant vous donner à
quelqu'un il va falloir compter et un
modèle qui malgré tout même si son prix
reste qu'à mlv n'est pas si cher que ça
aujourd'hui il y avait sur facebook
la kinect qui note une présentation
virtuelle je dirais surtout pour voir
qu'on est sur un téléphone qui coûte en
prix neuf je te dise pas de conneries
549 euros avec deux accessoires
franchement c'est un produit qui tient
vraiment très très bien déjà on a un
écran 5,7 pouces donc on est plus sur
les écrans tout petit les trois écrans
qui sont quand même assez important 5,7
pouces par rapport à samsung et suite
qui fait sens greg lui pousse tu vois
qu'on est juste en dessous en termes de
dimensions au niveau de la gamme aux 5,8
pouces
c'est à nantes un processeur oct accord
qui rate of 160 à 2,4 gigahertz qui en
réalité 18 18 % plus rapide que son
prédécesseur et au niveau de la puce
graphique on est sur une malijai 71ème
p8 qui est 180% plus performante que son
prédécesseur au niveau de la mémoire on
est exactement sur la même mémoire que
le sa leçon gratuite et suit plus on est
sur un 64 gigaoctets de mémoire et au
niveau de la ram on est sur du 6
gigaoctets drame donc on est sur un
produit qui est quand même avec une avec
une belle puissance introduit qui va
quand même booster qui va être qui
complètement dans les normes actuelles
tout arrive vraiment d'avoir un
smatphone rapide pour un prix qui est
vraiment hyper intéressant alors on
continue au niveau de la dalle on est
sûr alors pour ceux qui penseraient que
j'ai plein plein de téléphone et que je
suis riche
ce sont des produits de démonstration
certains mis juste d'avoir quelque chose
pour illustrer mon propos et je n'ai pas
le nouveau produit au nord entre les
mains j'adorerais mais je ne vais pas
d'ailleurs tu peut remarquer les deux
général tous mes téléphones sont en
carton
voilà qui revient qui n'est pas en
carton c'est celui là à là c'est mon psy
c'est ce qui me sert à faire la
présentation mais sinon en règle
générale tous les produits que je
présente je les ai pour l'instant
malheureusement pas
hirsch sur l'appel au nord à samsung et
apple si vous voulez nous envier c'est
un grand plaisir en tout cas là ce poste
me déplacer pour mener les voir avec
vous sinon j'ai zappé mais bon on s'en
fout ce n'est pas le sujet du jour elle
aura pour le compte y est une balle ip
est ce qu hd1 1440 par 2005 160 pixels
une résolution de 5 115 pixels par pouce
je suis vraiment technique là on parlera
après des choses un petit peu moins
technique mais pour l'instant il faut
quand même défini un produit il faut
savoir que le l'écran utilise 79% de la
face avant que ce qui permet
effectivement d'avoir quand même un
d'écran qui quand même relativement
grand par rapport à la taille du produit
on sait très bien aujourd'hui avec les
nouveaux samsung et puis on attend le
prochain iphone 8
excuse-moi la fuite on sait très bien
qu'on est sur des bordures relève des
écrans incurvés bon ça pour installer un
borderless et un écran incurvé sur un
produit je dirais d'entrée de gamme en
termes financiers ça poutre est quand
même très cher et ça ferait rapidement
augmenter l'addition pour l'instant on a
introduit qui est quand même extrêmement
franc je t'invite à aller voir le site
dehors du drac le produit vraiment très
très bon enfant extrêmement fins
excuse-moi des bordures qui sont
vraiment très très fine par rapport à la
taille de l'écran on a pas de bouton
home en bas on a quelque chose de très
fort au donc on est sur un produit de
bonne facture et qui corresponde je
dirais aux standards actuels
côté photo côté capteur photo on a deux
capteurs photo à l'arrière de capteur de
12 mégapixels chacun en couleurs noir et
blanc pourquoi noir et blanc j'en sais
absolument rien d'autant plus que sur
toutes les applis photo qui peut très
bien avoir des modes noir et blanc et tu
peux
les travailler avec des contrastes avec
ta cours des choses très sympas pourquoi
est ce que au nord a été nous va être un
capteur en noir et blanc va savoir
toujours est il qu'on allait de capteur
de 12 mégapixels
le couleur et noir et blanc directement
à l'arrière à face à par contre on a un
capteur de 8 mégapixels permettra quand
même des photos de bonne qualité au
niveau de la charge au niveau de la
batterie
là aussi il ya des choses qui ont
vraiment été super bien fait on est sur
une batterie qui est quand même
extrêmement puissante
ils annoncent deux jours d'utilisation
pour un petit peu moins de deux heures
de recharge
alors peut-être un petit peu moins de
deux jours si tu utilises à fond tu joue
énormément écoute sur le site énormément
toujours est il qu'ils nous disent que
on ya une charge rapide de 15 minutes
pour avoir une heure d'utilisation
supplémentaires ce qui fait que si tu as
très très peu de temps en réalité de
charges entre deux avions moins tragique
quelque chose d'un petit peu rapide tu
prends ton téléphone tu le branche sales
charge tu peux l'utiliser pendant une
heure c'est idéal pour les appels
d'urgence et pour les appelle un petit
peu rapide cité perdue cette zone
trouver quelqu'un pour chevron être que
tu veux ça c'est extrêmement pratique au
niveau du système au niveau de l' os
on est sur un android 7 avec une
surcouche em ui 5.1
c'est un produit qui peut trouver en
trois couleurs en bleu en noir ou encore
ta vie tu vraiment aller voir sur leur
site tu verras que le produit est
vraiment super jolie en bleu d'ailleurs
les autres aussi après ça reste une
question
autre point qui est super intéressant
sur téléphone je te dis là 64 giga de
mémoire interne
si tu souhaites tu peux le booster en
mémoire si tu souhaites rajouter 64
gigas je pense qu'il y aura peut-être
une limite supérieure à 128 je suis pas
suivant dessus je vais pas m'avancer
puis j'ai rien trouvé sur leur site par
contre toujours est il que au niveau de
l'emplacement outils de remettre la
carte sim à la possibilité avec un
emplacement au dessus soit de mettre une
deuxième carte sim je pense totalement
aux professionnels avec une carte sim
perso une carte sim procès temps mais
d'avoir les deux sur le même téléphone
ça c'est génial
et si tu souhaites pas mettre une
deuxième carte sim qui peut mettre une
carte mémoire une microsd directement la
place
si tu souhaites booster en mémoire qu'en
téléphone je pense pour ajouter des
films
tout ce que tu veux des photos des
vidéos tu peux le faire et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant ça permet
effectivement des choix par rapport à
l'utilisation ton téléphone c'est un
produit sont qualifés ctive mans on est
dans la tendance actuelle c'est à dire
pas de bouton home physique
il ya des boutons sur les côtés qui ne
serviront effectivement à commander le
téléphone à appuyer pouvoir débrouiller
à faire différentes choses et par contre
il ya un capteur d'empreintes digitales
qui est placé à l'arrière du smartphone
c'est pareil en aidant les standards
actuels
samsung l'a fait avec son époux était
sans issue plus apple devra très
probablement avec son iphone 8
on verra son adjoint toujours est il que
sur ce produit au nord tu as un bouton
derrière pour avoir ton petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales et pour
déverrouiller en un coup ton téléphone
au niveau du tarif c'est un produit qui
est en pré commande au tarif de 549
euros normalement de ce que j'ai vu il
ya une sortie le 25 avril tu peux déjà
le départ le pré commande air atteint
aujourd'hui alors tu vas voir sur leur
site un il ya différentes possibilités
pour l'instant tu peux tu l'achète pas
news téléphone tu vas la taille des
accessoires à ce tarif là mais bon peu
importe ça reste quand même très
intéressant tu peut le commander avec un
trépied une carte mémoire
tu peut le commander avec un casque vers
une carte mémoire enfin il ya trois
autres sont différentes
c'était quand même économiser pas loin
de 200 euros sur le coup téléphone tous
accessoires
donc c'est pas mal moins ce que je te
conseille réellement c'est de prendre le
téléphone site intéresse avec le casque
vert d'autant plus que lors de la
présentation qui a eu sur facebook
ils ont effectivement montré que dans le
boîtier de ton téléphone tu le lever il
y avait une espèce de cartons
fabrication carton pour pouvoir faire
des lunettes de verre pour découvrir la
vr je dirais donc ta de lentilles à
l'intérieur tout est ton téléphone au
fond tu le plaque sur ton visage et ça
te permet d'expérimenter la verrière
directement sur un module en carton
c'est pas mal pour découvrir
c'est franchement pas idéal enfin passer
deux heures comme ça à regarder un film
à jouer ou à balader en vr par contre
c'est pour ça que c'est très intéressant
d'aller acquérir ce casque vert
directement au tarif de 549 euros
si tu souhaites prendre ce téléphone je
te parle de la réalité virtuelle on en a
déjà parlé un tour de téléphonie
notamment pour le dernier samsung
ça me saoule les lieux à fond dans la
réalité virtuelle on sent effectivement
que au nord prend aussi lé pas des
créateurs de contenu en poussant à
cotonou on d'aller sur la terre de
toutes façons c'est la grande tendance
actuelle tout nova sur l'avers on arrive
à ça me son billet ap le livre a aussi
tout le monde va y aller donc c'est
vraiment un pays à prendre pour tous les
créateurs contenu je vais essayer de me
coller d'ici quelques temps et j'invite
tout le monde à le faire c'est vrai que
si tu veux pas achetée un samsung qui
veut acheter un apple tu prends au nord
c'est vraiment bien d'avoir donc à ce
que de venir parce que ça serait quand
même dommage de priver de cette
technologie qui va énormément développée
pour les films pour youtube pour
énormément de choses sous cette
immersion pour les jeux ça serait
vraiment top est justement puisqu'on
parle de jeu ce qui est génial avec ce
ce nouveau téléphone ceux qui vendent un
petit dongle que tu vas branché dessous
avec un eu un port en usb c'est qui
permettra de faire plusieurs choses et
notamment de brancher une manette de
console sauf erreur de ma part ils l'ont
fait sur la présentation avec une
manette de playstation
tu branches on engueule claque tu as ta
manette de playstation et tu peux jouer
directement dessus ils ont effectivement
présenté leur jeu galaxy on fire 3 qu à
l'heure quand même relativement sympa
bon moi je suis pas un grand fan de ce
genre de joie mais il a l'air de tenir
les d'être un jeu sympa priori à des
jeux de course pas mal de choses donc
qu'à brancher ta manette à une autre
expérience que juste jouer sur un
téléphone avec deux touches
tu poses ton téléphone tu as une manette
en termes de gaming c'est vraiment sympa
et
en termes d'expérience utilisateur c'est
vraiment cool donc ça serait dommage de
s'en priver
si tu aimes la verse et aiment les jeux
si tu veux un téléphone qui tient la
route avec calais tous les standards
actuels
tu as le au nord huit pros qui est
fondamentalement pas très cher et que je
te conseille un téléphone qui est pas
très cher je dirais idéal pour les
petits budgets
oui et non on est quand même à 549 euros
nu sans abonnement il faut voir après
les arrangements l édile qui rompt avec
les distributeurs les opérateurs
toujours est il que 549 euros
on peut pas dire quand même que ces
cadeaux on n'est pas sur un téléphone à
300 euros
on est quand même 300 euros en dessous
du prix du samsung du et suite par
contre 500 à plus de 500 euros il faut
quand même les sortir pour un téléphone
avoir comme ceux qui le disaient en
fonction de ce qui va arriver sur le
marché sur les différentes offres
honorera vraiment une politique
marketing si tu veux c'est ne pas
investir trop d'argent dans le marketing
pour avoir des téléphones avec les
dernières technologies au meilleur prix
sauf que voilà on peut pas dire
effectivement toutefois le téléphone
petit budget par contre si tu vas
comparer je dirais par rapport à
l'iphone j'ai comparé avec l'iphone est
ce on est sensiblement dans les mêmes
tarifs alors l'iphone est ce c'est pas
la même chose
attention cette offre qui est en train
de dire l'iphone et sur un écran qui
quand même beaucoup plus petit ils ont
une capacité qui a été boosté la
dernière manche 3 qui est monté à 128
giga sur la la dernière mouture de
l'iphone est ce mais tu prend 2,32
julien on est à 489 euros
mais tu prends le 100 m julien on est à
599 euros on est à 50 euros près 50 60
euros près dans le même budget que le
haut normand
tout ça pour dire que pour le prix d'un
au nord tu peux avoir un iphone 9
alors c'est le lse il est plus petit
c'est pas la même puissance
bon il ya quand même certaines
différences toujours est il que on peut
pas dire que ce téléphone là soit
aujourd'hui le téléphone low cost en
termes de caractéristiques on va plus se
rapprocher pas exactement de suite mais
il ya des points de comparaison en tout
cas avec le lait suite avec le 17 mai
voilà c'est un téléphone qui est boostée
par rapport à la version 8 l'a8 pro est
quand même beaucoup plus musclé beaucoup
plus intéressante fatalement moins cher
qu'un samsung donc si t'as pas le budget
et pour t'acheter directement ça me
saoule nu ensuite tu peut switcher sur
le au nord 8 trop qui est somme toute
bonne facture malgré tout ça reste un
budget dis moi tu vois ce que tu en
penses c'est ce que tu connaissais au
nord parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
forcément la marque la plus connue du
grand public
par contre c'est une marque qui tient
vraiment la route qui fonctionne depuis
très nombreuses années qu'ils créent des
produits de très bonne qualité dans
cette période où tout le monde sort
nouvelle version de son smartphone qui
va être vraiment la version un peu
boosté est-ce que tu serais plus ardue
samsung sur l'iphone kurde au nord il ya
plein d'autres produits aussi qu'ils
vont sortir y avoir acheté ces il
devrait y avoir d'autres marques qui
vont effectivement faire connaître leur
nouveau président dis moi ce que t'en
penses tu me tout en commentaire puis
enfin rendez vous très bientôt
ciao